that was like what we did in middle
school because there was no phones or
anything just like
punching punching people because they
farted that was that was how you passed
the time now it's like they're doing
these videos and you go up what who do
you think is most attractive in school
you know yeah we never had any of that
[__] punching people because they farted
is such a funny that's what we did
that's how you also like you know told a
girl that you had a crush on her yeah
you wait until she farts on me punch her
yeah dude oh my God what am I
one of my good friends growing up is
this story about an elementary school he
had a crush on some girl there's some
game where you punch people and he just
walks up to her and he just sucks the
[__] out of her arm she's like ow why
would you do that and everyone's like
bro what the hell is your problem he's
like I thought it was the game does it
work yeah dude they're married yeah nice
yeah hell no it did not work at all